[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv a
broadcast on thursday the 2nd of
december i'm fridge nelson
in this week's show is the nhs really
the envy of the world kate andrews says
the health service is actually falling
apart in her cover story for this week's
magazine she'll be on to explain
also new research shows that people were
protected from covid before the virus
was ever created apparently because of
their exposure to the common cold we
speak to the scientist behind that study
and ask relevance if any this has for
vaccine manufacturing
china is leading the world in hypersonic
missile technology is that something for
us to worry about does it work in the
first place and is china winning in the
new cold war we're going to be talking
to andrew coburn about his theory of why
we shouldn't after all worry about china
and then christianity in the middle east
janine giovanni spent 30 years reporting
from war zones where she noticed the
steady erosion of christianity
especially after the dictators were
toppled what went wrong she'll be coming
on to discuss
and finally we'll be looking at the
music of the beatles the beach boys and
bob dylan and asking did these three
artists influence each other and if so
how ian leslie reviews the book about
that for this week's magazine and
discusses the musical overlaps you might
not have known existed but before we get
going if you haven't subscribed to this
youtube channel then please do you it's
absolutely free all you need to do is
click on the red subscribe button
underneath the screen if you click the
wee bell then you'll be alerted to every
time there's a new episode and if you
don't subscribe to the spectator we'd
like to make you a special introductory
offer for just 12 pounds you can get 12
weeks to the magazine 12 weeks full
digital access and a 20 quid amazon
voucher if you do the maths you work out
that our marketing department has made a
mistake it doesn't stack up but you
might as well take their money you go to
spectator dot co dot uk forward slash tv
offer
in our cover story this week kate
andrews asks if the nhs is fit for
purpose she rather suggests not she
joins me now with matthew taylor who's
chief executive of the nhs confederation
now kate um britain's been through a
pandemic we're bracing ourselves for
whatever the consequences are of omicron
variant of course the health service is
going to be stressed and strained
so why do you think that there's
something more fundamentally wrong going
on well as you say fraser the pandemic
has knocked not only the nhs but
essentially every developed uh country's
healthcare system throughout the world
so of course it's going to be more
strained it's going to be a more
difficult
state but the truth is that the idea of
a winter crisis is not unique to coming
out of a pandemic or being in a pandemic
these are the usual headlines that we
would see for the nhs nearly every
winter for quite a long time now the
idea that you would pull the lever to
cancel elective surgeries is also not
new we've been talking about that in the
wake of the pandemic the fact that in
some areas they're being cancelled again
but that happened in 2018 because the
health care service could barely cope so
what i'm highlighting in the article for
the magazine this week is that yes every
country has had a very difficult time
with covid and the strains and the extra
demand as more patients who weren't seen
last year coming forward this year is
going to be adding to that burden
although it's an important burden
because those people should be coming
forward but the major difference is that
we have known for decades now when we
look at international comparisons that
the nhs has been struggling it's often
ranked mediocre it is far from the envy
of the world so i think now coming out
of covet hopefully goodness forbid
something should change on that front
this is the time that we need to start
seriously talking about what the other
options are not looking to the usa which
is usually the default nhs versus usa
but looking to the rest of the developed
world that also offers universal access
to health care but the emerging data
does seem to be that many of those
countries fared better in the pandemic
and are faring better coming out of the
pandemic mafia taylor when you were
working for tony blair health service
was pretty much half what it is now it's
gone from 8.1 percent of gdp to 13 of
gdp for overall health spending if money
was going to be the problem wouldn't we
have the best health service in the
world i suspect even you wouldn't be as
bold to say that we do right now
i think our health service uh and there
are lots of different ways of measuring
this but it's probably
overall funded slightly less well than
similar health services
and it achieves outcomes which vary uh
in some areas they're quite good in
other areas they're not so good
so i think it's important not to
believe that our health services is
perfect or even that it's uh to quite a
phrase world beating
to recognize its strengths but also to
recognize that it needs to change but
you know it is very important to
recognize that rising health costs is a
global phenomenon and particularly in
developed countries which have aging
populations because it is indeed the
aging of the population which is the big
driver of health and care costs i don't
think there's anything intrinsic to our
nhs model
universal health care free at the point
of delivery
that i don't think is is is what is
wrong with the health service it's
common to every country pretty much
isn't it every country in the developed
world apart from america is free at the
point of use
yeah i so i i think when we look at what
we need to do with a health service to
get it back on its feet i think first of
all you know it is important to
recognize that between 2010 and 2020 we
had the decade with the lowest growth in
health spending that we have ever seen
in the health service history around
half the trend increase in health
spending that you tend to see in
countries because as i say of that aging
population and the consequence of that
was a health service with fewer nurses
per head fewer hospital beds fewer
doctors per head than most other
countries like us and a system like that
a system that runs on hot most of the
time is particularly vulnerable to
external shocks and that's why
covid has a had a particularly
challenging effect uh on our population
and on our health service right matthew
that figure i quoted 13 of gdp that's
higher than any country in europe any
country in the world except the united
states i mean you cannot really say that
britain lacks for health spending
because we literally spend more as a
share of our economy than anybody else
besides the us
i think if you look at public health
spending we rank below the average in
the eu 14 we're just about average for
the oecd so you can look at this from
various perspectives is it public
spending is it private expecting
spending is it is it total spending i
don't
you know in in a sense
the question of of as it will disconnect
substantial question of whether or not
the health service works i'm not sure
where it takes us there is no public
appetite for
changing the core principles of the
health service any attempt to do that
would be massively disruptive which is
the last thing that we need now i think
instead we need to focus on the
practical challenges that the health
service faces and also and this is
critical the opportunities which are
going to be provided by digital by data
by medtech
those offer the opportunity to make a
real difference to our health service in
the coming years and i think that
that's really the thing we should focus
on how can the health service take
advantage of those shifts to achieve a
step change in the quality of its
service
so kate the health service is reasonably
funded and is doing a reasonable job
well look i think we can measure
healthcare spending in all kinds of ways
but a percentage of gdp spent on on
healthcare has often been the way that
people look at it and one of the reasons
is because if you go back say a decade
the nhs was relatively average in the
oecd so that was a convenient metric to
say that the issue is more money we need
more funding that's always the go-to
whenever the nhs has a problem we simply
say we need more funding now this has
changed quite radically and recently
because boris johnson after putting nhs
pledges on the side of a brexit bus has
really decided to double down on that
try to make the tories the party of the
nhs and so far he's not doing that with
reform he's he's doing that with money
but in 2020 the metric that is so
frequently used to look at health care
spending does put the uk second highest
in all of the oecd so those countries
that are often cited for having better
funding germany switzerland france that
also get better outcomes have have
fallen behind the nhs on that metric and
if we look between 2010 and what we
estimate by 2025 uh the health care
budget the nhs budget will have gone up
by 42 percent and i think if we look at
something like schools it's roughly
three percent
in the next election the day-to-day
public service spending is going to be
roughly 44
of the whole budget we're getting quite
close to having a health care service
with a government attached and i think
it's very important crucial that in
these next few years given the fact that
we have the system we do we focus on
getting those resources to the front
lines and to supporting the doctors and
nurses who are trying to help patients
but we cannot keep funneling money into
what is so clearly a broken system and
the money that we were spending in 2020
just doesn't seem to on the preliminary
data have gotten us the outcomes we
wouldn't have wanted let's go back to
lockdown last year look at the oncology
appointments for cancer patients in
germany they dropped by 33 that's a
stark figure but in the uk they dropped
by 60 percent
if you look at swedish breast cancer
patients uh the those that were being
seen dropped by 10 in the uk it was 30
percent
if the money we were spending last year
alone we should be doing better on these
metrics so in the next few years yes by
all means let's try to be efficient but
we clearly have more to learn from other
systems and i think we need to stop
being so blinded as to what they're
doing right because as matthew says that
that principle of universal access to
health care is so deeply important but
for the person waiting for their
ambulance to show up who's losing hope
or for the person who still can't see
their gp
you know free at the point of use is
losing its relevance the nhs is not
there for them and surely that is really
the point to get people access to care
matthew what do you make of that point
then that's non-coveted care during the
pandemic was far worse hit in britain
than it was in other countries i mean
kate said the cancer care for example
took a way bigger hit here than it did
in sweden if you look at knee operations
hip operations they went down far more
here by about 45 50 percent than they
did in ireland and italy where they went
down by about half of that level so why
is it in denmark they actually went up
so why is it other countries are able to
carry on their non-coded care when in
britain we've seen that knocked for six
and a waiting list of something like 5.6
million people
so this is why it seems to me that bold
statements like you know the nhs is
broken the nhs doesn't work it doesn't
really get us anywhere you know it's a
it's it's kind of a level of generality
which is fine for political posturing
but no good when it comes to actually
practical steps so why well the simple
reason is the way in which we run our
health service
has been to minimize the number of beds
statistics are all over the place at the
moment because of kobe but one thing
that was pretty commonly seen about our
health service was that it was a you
know a pretty efficient health service
even if some of its outcomes were were
not what we would want them to be
if you talked to
doctors even before kovid
and you talked about the the occupancy
rates we had in hospitals in the summer
people in other countries continentally
would be amazed that we would occupancy
rates between 80 80 percent plus in the
summer when
uh you know in other countries this
would have been unheard of he would be
taking holidays things would be there'd
be a lot of of give in the system that's
not how we run things we run things so
that you know we do have uh difficult
winters every winter we do get people
out hospitals
we do have high quality rates so when a
crisis like covid happens there is no
slack in the system that's the way that
our system has been uh designed that's
right is that a good thing do you think
i mean it sounds to me like a pretty bad
thing that we run it a bad for doctor
it's bad for patients every winter we
seem to be in a crisis mean surely there
must be a better way of going to europe
it doesn't happen to the same degree now
you're saying yes it's efficient if you
look at the proportion of beds that are
filled but that seems to be a rather
strange way of defining efficiency if
you define it for for patient care for
example if you define it in terms of
patient outcomes surely that's way more
efficient than what proportion of the
beds are filled and isn't it the nhs way
of doing it maximizing the bed occupancy
rationing health care hasn't that become
the problem
so i think if you look at the way in
which the nhs has been resourced over
the last few years one of the problems
has been feast and famine you know we
saw a lot of extra money going under new
labor i think looking back
not as much reform not as much progress
should have been made a lot was made you
know by the time labour left office we
were meeting those key targets for
waiting lists emergency departments
elective care making real progress we
then move into these 10 years of
austerity with spending increasing at
less than half the
annual global increase in developed
countries you expect in the health
service
what that has led to
is major capacity issues so we have
major capacity issues in terms of the
capital of the health you know the
health service you know hospitals in a
very poor state of repair not made the
investment we should have made in areas
like digital and of course the number
one problem right now which is workforce
you know we did not plan sufficiently we
did not invest efficiently and now
actually we've got a situation health
service where where in the short term at
least there is the cash but people don't
know how to spend it because we don't
have the workforce because it takes
several years to put that workforce in
place and yet even now
we are pressing the government to
publish more regular
workforce plans and there's a push back
against that why is there a push back
against that because if you publish
workforce plans for the health service
it comes with a price tag attached and
the government does not want to see that
price tag in the public domain
so it isn't just about the level of
resource unfortunately we've gone
through this feast and famine and that
has left us in a position where kovitz
struck where where our capacity in areas
like capital in areas like workforce was
not where it needed to be and we've
suffered as a consequence so kate
andrews and matthew taylor is saying it
comes back to resources there there was
not much tourist but there was not much
health spending during the austerity
years we're now looking at the
consequences of that decision to slow
down and not exactly cut but slow down
on nhs spending when we should have been
investing the result the disaster that
we see now
well to be very clear the nhs budget was
going up in real terms every year it was
just that it was going up perhaps less
than others would have liked to see it
go up and i think a lot of this also
comes down to priority about where the
money that has been funneled in actually
went to whether or not it went to
management or whether or not it went to
the front line it's very clear that some
of those priorities were perhaps in the
wrong order um you know i think
matthew's highlighted very well that
this is a system that is intentionally
designed to run hot the way you argue
you are efficient is to not have spare
capacity to not have spare beds to not
have spare workers to always be
operating on the brink and i think covet
highlighted a lot of things number one
do you want a health care system that
does that but number two
with the nhs logo being used to convince
people to stay home you know protect the
nhs as i mentioned in an article a
senior source um on the health side on
the nhs side said you know test and
trace had nothing to do with us they
wanted to use that nhs logo because it's
so powerful that kept a lot of people
home now they're coming back the demand
is rising i still don't think the
resources are in the right place but
this should make us question overall
whether or not this is the kind of
system that we can live with for the
next pandemic because whether if our
freedoms are really tied to nhs capacity
it's going to be a rough life uh for for
all of us in the coming years because as
i mentioned at the beginning nhs
capacity is an issue every winter not
just with covet then after that i think
you have to go back frankly decades look
at these international comparisons and
while we are all quite rightly talking
about the value of life and what we all
did on and off for the past two years to
protect life to to to respect individual
life we need to look at the fact that if
cancer patients were treated in other
countries from four of the most common
types of cancer in say germany or say
belgium thousands more lives a year
could potentially be saved in short the
system really does matter so this is a
time if you really want to protect that
that principle of universal access to
health care if you want more resources
for the nhs if you would like to see it
better funded but for those for and it
is going to be better funded from next
year with the health and social care
levy if you actually want to see that
money put to good use you have to
address the system and that's going to
have to come from whitehall from the
people in charge and they're going to
have to be courageous because for a very
long time politicians simply have not
been able to criticize the healthcare
service it has become a national
religion but it is one that is not doing
us any good
kate andrews and matthew taylor thanks
very much indeed
now when kobet first came along there
was talk that if you'd had a common cold
you might be protected from it
at the time it was seen to be a pretty
out there theory but research from
university college london suggests there
might be something in this after all
professor maddie nor saderi joins me now
professor tell us about your research
yes that thanks thanks for the
invitation to come along and talk about
this um so i i'm part of a large uh
research collaboration called covert
sortium um and when the code 19 first
emerged in early 2020 it was already
becoming apparent very quickly
that many people experienced
asymptomatic or very mild disease
and we
thought that a possible determinant of
this particular outcome so a reason why
some people might develop asymptomatic
or mild infection
is that they might have very early
immune responses
that stop the infection from taking hold
to be able to find these very early
immune responses we would need samples
from participants at risk of infection
before during and after exposure
and to do that we had to start really
early and be able to collect samples
before the wave sort of spread through
the uk
and we were able to start our study at
the very beginning of the first lockdown
in london
by recruiting some 400 healthcare
workers who are particularly at high
risk of being exposed in the very first
week
and
then
follow these people up over time to see
who would become infected and try to
identify
those who might be exposed but be able
to resist that infection and what we
found is that uh in a subset of people
probably about one in ten that we were
able to study
um
uh
showed evidence of an immune response to
the internal machinery of the virus that
would stop the virus from taking hold or
as an infection
and what's really interesting is that
this immune response to the internal
machinery
means
really relates to components of the
virus that are very highly conserved
between
different coronavirus species
and if we could harness this sort of
immune response in vaccines then that
would give us the opportunity to develop
a
pan coronavirus vaccine or at least a
vaccine that was much more resilient to
new variants emerging are we talking
about the t-cell response here a
t-cell-mediated response
yes that's right so um the immune system
as you'll be aware has involved several
lines of defense and there's been
lots and lots of discussion of antibody
responses um to to the virus and and
antibodies are the primary target of the
main vaccines that are currently
available
um but
the vaccines and natural infection also
induce
a t cell response and t cells do two
sorts of things they either help the
body produce antibodies or indeed can
seek out and destroy virally infected
cells themselves
so um they they make for a very
important part of the immune response
and um
what we found is that
this subset of individuals had t cells
that could recognize um components of
the virus that as i say were shared
between many different coronavis and
interestingly you think they may have
come by this t-cell immunity or t-cell
memory by exposure to the common cold of
whom i think i'm writing saying about a
quarter to a third of the common cold
are responsible
are and use the corona viruses
yes that's right so most of um
what we could describe as the common
cold is due to coronaviruses and
the
the parsimonious explanation the most
likely explanation for why people at the
very beginning of the epidemic wave in
2020 would have some t-cell immunity or
cell memory is that the this t cell
memory was was generated by previous
exposure to other coronavirus vaccine
right now this seems to be a very
important part of the um corona puzzle
um but there hasn't been much research
on t-cells if i want to find out if i've
got antibodies i can go down to a clinic
around the corner i can pay them 50 quid
they can tell me quite quickly
if i want to find out if i've got a t
cell response
how is that done is it is it more
difficult to to measure t cells than
antibodies
yeah that's right it is more it is
technically more difficult and one of
the reasons that antibodies are easy to
measure is because we can measure them
in in
a fraction of a blood sample called
serum that doesn't need much laboratory
processing and can be easily collected
and run through assays
to find these t cells
we need to collect the cellular fraction
that requires much more laboratory work
up front before we can do an assay
and
the assays are more difficult because
the frequency of these v these um t
cells uh makes up for a very small
fraction of the total t cell population
and so we've had to develop assays that
are super sensitive so that we can
identify these t cells so could you give
us some res i mean in crude terms if it
takes a matter of hours to do
a an antibody response how long would it
take you
to test one person for t cells
so actually once you have an assay
that's developed uh then
um the
uh the the actual measurement is quite
straightforward and we can do it in
within 24 hours really because we
haven't seen very much in the way of t
cell i can be fairly abreast of these
things i haven't seen very much in the
way of t cell testing or or studies
which ask for example let's take a blood
sample of people taken before covert 19
came on the scene how many of those
people have got t cells i mean the large
well institute in california came up
with an estimate right at the beginning
of the pandemic where they looked at
blood samples taken before covert and
they found a surprising number had
covered m relevant t cells but since
then it hasn't really been part of the
conversation i assumed because people
yeah this is the argument
that's correct because um
uh so so uh you're absolutely right
there it hasn't certainly been in the
public eye so much uh but actually in
the sort of research community there's
been a huge amount of work done on
t-cells one of the great difficulties
has been to prove that these
pre-existing t-cells
were actually responsible for protecting
people from infection and the reason
that our study was helpful it was
because of the study design that
captured people before during and after
the infection allowed us to really show
that clearly that actually these
pre-existing t cells were expanding in
response to
the exposure to infection and blocking
the infection from taking hold so is
there any estimate of how much of the
population actually had some degree of t
cell protection before kevin 19 came on
the scene
yeah we don't know that it's really
really difficult to prove that
experimentally
because the collections are not
necessarily available and the um
nor the sort of outcomes of what happens
to everybody
uh is necessarily available these sort
of studies are not really possible to do
now because so many people have been
exposed to the sarskof2 virus
or else to to vaccinations that also
will induce t-cell responses
going forward would be to would need us
to integrate these components into a
vaccine and then look at the efficacy of
the vaccine right so
if i want to find out if i've got t-cell
immunity is that possible can i do that
in research projects that's certainly
possible um there are i know of
commercial sort of
efforts to to
develop these assays as a commercial
test but their real application in in
sort of routine clinical care is not
very
um well-defined at the moment and at the
moment it's rather speculative exactly
what it means for an individual person
um i think going forward into the future
uh particularly as if we're able to
incorporate uh
components of the virus in next
generation vaccines that are really uh
targeting t cells uh then i think uh
they'll become they'll come to the fore
much more but let's look at the um the
vaccines we've got right now the mrna
viruses like pfizer moderna even the
slightly old-school vaccine from them
oxfords and astra
they sure they solicit antibodies
responses but they also solicit t-cell
response don't they
yes that's right
but the the the responses that they
generate are uniquely to the spike
protein that is encoded in the vaccine
um
and
the the difference between
that sort of t cell response
and the t cell responses that we're
describing is that the spike protein is
extremely variable and can be um
mutated much more readily
than the internal machinery of the virus
that is that is required for the virus
to undergo its life cycle
so the important thing is really to
think about the next generation of
vaccines that include more than just the
spike protein
to include these
internal components of the virus that
can't vary so much but they do this
already don't they i mean most vaccines
available will give you a t-cell
response the sort that you're talking
about
yeah
so so this is the i guess the the really
crucial point
the existing vaccines only generate
anti-immunity antibody and t cell
responses to the outer shell of the
virus called the spike protein
the spike protein is very variable and
new variants will mutate its spike
protein to be able to escape uh the
immunity generated by the vaccine so you
think it's scientifically possible then
to develop a vaccine that will target
not the outer shell but the core of the
coronavirus so there ought to be a way
that will come up that will protect us
against not just the existing variants
but all future variants in the same way
that the people you discovered with ex
with t cells from exposure to the common
cold are protected we can give you that
sort of mutation for all variants of
coronaviruses is it scientifically
possible
yeah precisely i mean that's exactly why
we're really excited about these results
is because they give us
the best evidence so far that targeting
other parts of the virus can be
protective and the these other parts of
the virus the internal core as you
describe them
do not vary as much of as much as the
outer shell and therefore they will
generate or potentially generate more
durable vaccines so how do you do this
do we need can it be done via mrna
vaccines degeneration or is it simply a
new way of just simply old school
exposing people to the
antigen hoping the immune system does
its magic
yeah they know they can definitely be
gener
encoded into
the new generation of vaccines the new
mrna vaccines for example can be we
would just use um sequences that
lead to the production of these
core components of the virus rather than
the spike protein
in fact a more mature way of thinking
about this actually is that the next
generation of vaccines might include
many components of the virus encoded by
the mrna so the same technology can be
tweaked to be able to um present
different parts of the virus within the
vaccine
okay and it forces our time scale has
this been done before i mean i'm trying
to work out is it something which is
theoretically possible but it might take
10 years in the same way that people
have spoken about for example hiv
vaccines theoretically possible but
they're still not with us
yeah i mean two years ago i would have
said that this would take several years
to develop but now i'm pretty confident
that's not the case the the real
transformation as a result of the
pandemic has been um our discovery that
we can accelerate vaccine um development
to such an extent to really reduce it
within six to twelve months i think um
uh i i imagine that uh um
if it becomes apparent that new variants
are indeed escaping
vaccine-mediated protection that will be
enough motivation uh to focus everyone
on everyone's mind on the next
generation of vaccines and we could
probably turn that round in the next
three to six months the next three to
six months and you're aware of anybody
looking at this i mean there's a very
big world out there looking at new
vaccines the whole time somebody looking
at a t-cell mediated inner core vaccine
for for covert
yeah our group is not involved directly
in vaccine
development but really
identifying the the components of the
virus that we can incorporate into the
next generation of vaccines so so
yes there's ongoing conversations and
have been for some time with
people who are involved directly in
vaccine development to do exactly that
to develop that next generation
including other parts of the virus
rather than just the spike protein okay
and finally is there a time limit to
this because one of the things we've
noticed certainly with the mrna vaccines
is that they seem to the efficacy wanes
over time the israelis found this quite
strikingly but the very high protection
levels four months later were much lower
and is that because they were targeting
the outer shell i mean are you talking
here about a vaccine that would not need
to be chopped up every four to six
months or is that somehow a factor of
mrna
uh
no i think that
vaccines that primarily try to prevent
infection happening at all
probably have
are all susceptible to waning immunity
because the antibody levels drift down
slowly and that's what's probably the
first barrier
to
an infection taking hold
but
if you imagine the other purpose of
vaccines is to prevent severe disease
from happening then the durability of
vaccines is probably much better to
prevent severe disease
we also think that
vaccines that generate good t cell
responses are probably more durable than
those that just generate good antibody
responses
so i think as we go forward the focus
will probably
um
change slightly
for to develop a strategy that prevents
severe disease rather than necessarily a
strategy that just stops all
transmission of infection uh from
happening
nonetheless it's probably quite likely
that
the
we'll end up with a vaccine or an
approach to vaccination that involves
boosters at intervals
not unlike for example
boost annual boosters for flu vaccine
professor maddie northaderi thanks very
much for joining us on spectator tv
now next up do you remember the reports
last month about china developing a new
hypersonic nuclear-enabled missile that
was able to circumnavigate the world and
strike it turns out we were told that
american intelligence were quite
surprised by how advanced the chinese
technology were because they were more
advanced than the americans themselves
in this week's magazine andrew coborn
cast some doubts on this arguing that
the west has got a little bit carried
away with how advanced china might be he
joins me now as does my colleague cindy
you
andrew um
why aren't you worried about this
because the chinese obviously do have
the technology so what's to say that
they have not actually overtaken america
and russia with this new hypersonic
glide technology that everybody is
trying to develop
well there's a number of reasons um
you know they used to say the pentagon
talk about weapons that don't work to
make threats that don't exist and this
is a shining example of that um
first of all there are inherent reasons
why
a hypersonic missile which i should
quickly say simply means something that
travels at more than five times the
speed of sound
um
is not a very sort of worthwhile weapon
of war because the whole
point is that it should
fly a glide along it's boosted into
orbit by a
rocket
uh just like any space vehicle but then
is released at the just at the top of
the atmosphere
and
basically given an almighty shove by the
rocket and then
flies through the atmosphere toward its
target maneuvering using flying like an
airplane
um as an airplane in fact um
and the whole point of that is that
therefore you can't it's impossible to
track to know where it's going to be
with an ordinary ballistic missile you
know once it's set off and you can see
where it's going you know where it's
going to be and you can intercept it
theoretically
um and this gets around that that's
what's meant to be scary about it
except that
we don't have any defenses against
ballistic missiles anyway
um
you know they've been trying for years
they spent 200 million billion dollars
since ronald reagan unveiled the idea
back in 1983 and they still have got
almost nothing to show for it they're
still working out still spending
billions so
you know there's nothing new there's no
new threat here
and by the way
i've been trying to reduce a complicated
technological thing to brief sentences
in
maneuvering through the atmosphere the
thing quickly loses energy i mean every
you know it's like uh
you know
in the act of sort of
turning or diving or climbing it slows
down
so cindy if it's useless then why is the
chinese government spending so much
money on it
i think we have to look at where else in
the world is doing it because it's not
just the chinese and the americans it's
also the russians as andrew points out
in his article putin has made this a key
military facet since 2018 and the
chinese are following this you know when
we
if you look at um supersonic nuclear
missile if you search that in a chinese
search engine most of the articles that
come up about how ahead the russians are
so i do think we have to take that into
account that to china great power
competition isn't just about america
it's also about the other big beasts uh
in the world and fraser just to go back
to you on your point before about
chinese military capability being better
than the americans on new on ballistic
and cruise missiles they are but just on
that and the reason for that is because
of china's geography it's surrounded by
countries in a way that america is not
or countries potentially that you might
have um conflict with and so it has
concentrated on that part of its
capability in a way that america doesn't
have to so on that point it is better
than americans but that doesn't mean the
whole military as a whole is um better
than americans it still only spends less
than a third of the u.s defense uh
budget on its own defense even though
the army is much larger
andrew isn't that a decent point when
you look at the world's great defense
spenders china is pretty small i mean
your average nato country is supposed to
spend two percent of gdp on defense now
britain does france more or less but
most of them don't but china is
something like 1.7 so this does not look
like a a country which is really
budgeting for for conflict in the way
that we certainly saw we tend to see in
the build up to wars
well this is true and in fact i think
it's the case they still spend more
on their internal security apparatus for
keeping the
chinese people under control the
people's arms armed police and a huge
apparatus of censorship and all the rest
they spend more on that than they do on
their external military so all this tub
thumping that we see in the press you
know with
like the hypersonic missiles we're
discussing you know should be seen in
that context that they see
it looks like they see a bigger threat
from their own people than they do from
they you know any external enemies but
what about the military will build up in
the taiwanese and coasts there i mean
that can't be an internal threat i mean
that's right now that is the number one
focus of american attention and the the
understanding in washington and in
london is that china if it wanted to
could make an assault in taiwan pretty
quickly doesn't need missiles for that
it just needs boats to go a few miles
over the sea and annex uh currently
sovereign territory
well you know it's very easy to once you
sort of
put that all out in one sentence it all
makes it sound quite easy but you know
they've got
you know we in 1944
we the allies
went to enormous i mean took an enormous
effort
to move um and then an invading army 20
miles
across the channel
or slightly more than 20 miles but uh
but the chinese to go to taiwan is a
hundred miles um
they'd need more uh more than two
amphibious ships which is all they have
at the moment uh i mean amphibious
support ships
um
they probably might need more than
uh
two well i think they're heading for
four aircraft carriers uh i think one
they converted into a hotel but never
mind i mean it's it's it's it's a really
it's just a very silly idea i mean that
they that they and they keep saying we
don't think we could do this um
you know it's worth
looking at what the chinese say about
themselves
uh in the chinese literature and they
keep sort of complaining that the troops
aren't properly trained
they don't know how to use the weapons
that the whole thing's been disorganized
they haven't done a major exercise since
i think 2017.
uh and as for these you know incursions
into taiwanese airspace that we read so
much about the press if you look at the
map of where the planes actually went
they basically go along
one side of this
self-declared air defensive
identification zone which is not
national airspace
and fly along it maybe one plane a day
sometimes many more but i was the time
one plane then go home again it looks
more like training flights in fact the
taiwanese chief of staff said the other
day that's what they were
so cindy and how do you see this the
chinese people um seem to take
reasonable pride in the military china
still has military parades where the
latest weapons are put on them but on
display here i mean do they regard
military spending as a waste of money or
something that an up-and-coming nation
needs in order to stake its claim to be
the kind of the power in the region that
certainly seems to be and as you've
written before this is what she wants he
wants to be the top dog in asia for that
he will need a military capable of
projecting if he chooses to do so
yeah fraser i think it is much more
about national pride and i think people
are happy to spend this much money um
and you know the the dynamics that
andrew picks out in this military
industrial complex that happens in
america happens in china too because
once you big up the threat uh coming
from places like america as a chinese
person you're gonna want to defend
yourself from that
or you want to protect your territorial
claims for example in the south china
sea or fraser you said taiwan which i
would argue that the chinese do see as
an internal problem um as we know that
they argue about that so so for things
like that either it's for defense or for
securing your own interests in in its
near broad as it were um the chinese are
quite happy to spend money on that and
some of it is not though so the people's
liberation army has been undergoing
modernisation some of it is not about
spending more it's just about spending
more cleverly it's about reorganizing
it's about spending less on the army
more on the navy more on the space force
that sort of rejecting which is
something that presidency has very much
been looking at but one thing that
they've been lacking still is this kind
of capability to have joint missions so
to take taiwan you need to have air sea
and land operating together and at the
moment the chinese are still not quite
there yet with that so you can see in
the curriculum in military academies
where they're still kind of figuring out
what is the right approach to teach uh
its students so yes on that on that
joint capability part no amount of money
is going to be able to fix that in the
short term
cindy and andrew thanks very much indeed
now in this week's magazine we review
the latest book by janine de giovanni
she's been a work correspondent now an
academic at yale university she's
written about the plight of christianity
in the middle east she joins me now um
janine you've got um
so many stories inside you why did you
want to write this one about the fate of
religion
well basically i've been working in the
middle east for three decades and around
the time of saddam hussein in the early
2000s i became aware of the christian
communities in iraq now these are people
who are basically living in the land of
the prophets the land of jonah of saint
thomas and how they were in danger of
being eradicated entirely
since the rise of the islamic state in
2014 in places like iraq and syria these
communities who are very ancient very
rooted to their land are even more
vulnerable so what i decided was really
to focus on four very distinct
communities in the middle east in iraq
in syria in egypt and in the gaza strip
and why they are so desperately
important that these people remain in
their ancestral lands
now of course christianity was a middle
eastern exports and so therefore it's
been in the middle east for way longer
than it has been in europe and so why
should it be that after going through
two millennia of tumult in these
countries it's under its most in danger
now as you say in your book
absolutely well first of all it's very
interesting because most british
christians and american christians don't
really associate i mean they know that
jesus christ was born in bethlehem but
they don't really associate the birth of
christianity being in in the holy land
and that these ancient communities the
assyrians the calden caldians the cops
are such a unique part of biblical and
indeed history so really what recent
events um
have led to their
they could be even extinction within a
hundred years first of all is the rise
of radical groups so let's take the
islamic state one of their edicts was to
basically wipe out christians in that
part of iraq which was of course mosul
um and and the northern villages leading
into kurdistan the second thing and i
have to stress that each community has
their own individual challenges um so
for instance in iraq um it's geopolitics
but it really also is climate change um
iraq is one of the most vulnerable
countries in the middle east in terms of
climate change but it's also about
migration mass of vast migration that
these young people there's no industry
there's no incentive for them to stay
so
every community has a very different
story to tell the cops in egypt for
instance are extremely discriminated
against it's enshrined within the
egyptian constitution
that they cannot hold offices of high
position in the government or in the um
the army which of course is an arm of
the government um in the gaza strip it's
an entirely different thing there's only
800 christians left there and of course
christianity gaza had been entirely
christian until the 4th century so these
800 remaining people um are basically
sandwiched in between hamas
and the israeli
occupation even though the israelis
withdrew they are still very much
subjugating the people there the 11 day
bombing in may left gaza devastated
again again so each community has has
unique challenges that
are allowing them to remain and indeed
to populate because their numbers are
dwindling drastically but to what extent
were the dictators actually a friend of
the christians because let's take saddam
hussein for example his deputy from
memory tariq aziz was a christian um in
syria and the christians had an okay
time under assad it was when assad was
on the ropes but they started to get
worried and even in egypt the cops were
pretty much i mean correct me if i'm
wrong here but free to worship in peace
until its recent regime changes and only
then do you end up with them christians
in egypt being attacked outside their
churches so i wonder to what to extend
the the regime changes over the last two
decades have ushered in the forces which
ushered out the christians
absolutely this was one of the stranger
um things that i came across so you're
absolutely right the christians were
protected in iraq under saddam hussein
there was a sort of unofficial deal with
the devil that for their voting bloc
in exchange they would basically be left
alone
the same thing in syria and this is
something that really shocked me
especially as i reported the war in
syria um
when i would go to the christian
communities there they would you know
basically state their absolute love for
bashar al-assad now whether or not this
is a fear that they had to say this or
whether or not it's basically that they
felt we'd rather have assad than have
the devil that might come afterwards in
other words we do not want the black
flag
same with the christians under mubarak
in egypt
and then the ensuing chaos that led
after the egyptian revolution the muslim
brotherhood and as for the gazans um
they were probably the most closed
community it was the most difficult for
me to penetrate that community even
though i've been working in gaza since
1990
um
and i think basically they
most of the people said that hamas did
not bother them they were more what was
more disturbing for them was their
inability to leave gaza to join their
brethren in bethlehem for christmas or
easter and the israeli authorities
prevented them from doing that but
absolutely the link between christians
and dictators is very strong and very
very strange
all right and do you think that
christians um
you know who would leave any of these
countries could come to britain and
claim under the human definition a
reasonable fear of persecution because
from what you'd say in your book
it's a pretty brave guy who keeps going
to church right now in some of these
areas where you become a target if you
do so and now they are you also document
in your book cow they're leaving in
quite num in huge numbers ought they be
going to britain and america are not
they be received because and perhaps
because of part interventions there a
couple of decades ago but there are no
doubt under persecution now
absolutely and i mean so in 2017 2016
2017 when president trump issued his
muslim ban on refugees coming to the u.s
who were muslim
that did not include christians arab
christians now remember they're arabs
but they're christians and for me at
that time i was working for the u.n
refugee agency
it sent up a terrible message which is
that we have good refugees and we have
bad refugees i.e good refugees being
christian so christian communities in
britain
in france which is catholic country in
spain in italy and in the us generally
welcome canada as well is another big
point where where a lot of the
christians go generally welcome these
refugees whereas muslim refugees
especially now in the wake of the fall
of the taliban
are
flooding europe and elsewhere and this
has different considerations and
concerns
another thing is that the the taliban
falling
sends a terrible message
for these christian communities in the
middle east because it basically means
that
other radical groups and let's face it
the islamic state might have been
defeated but they are not gone they're
regrouping they're rebranding the
recruiting under different methods and
there are numerous other groups that
have been vastly empowered by the fall
of the taliban
so this leaves the christian communities
in iraq in syria in these other places
even more vulnerable which is why we
really have to draw attention to their
plate
and janine you met lots of these
christians these people who risked their
lives to show up to church did you get a
sense of why they were doing it why not
simply worship
in private why would you um risk
everything that you've got simply to
show up at your normal place of worship
if you're a clergyman why would you keep
doing that when you knew you'd be a
massive target for somebody and you'd be
safer seeking exile in a far away land
the answer that i got over and over was
one word love
all of them told me for instance when
the islamic state rolled through mosul
the christians that got out some of them
got out at the very last minute
literally with the clothes on their
backs and their documents but others
stayed in mosul and
the is the isis basically gave them a
choice you can convert or we kill you or
you pay a huge fee and they took their
farmland and they put the letter n for
nazarene over their door marking them as
followers of jesus now i totally agree
with you if i was tossed into the lion's
den as a as a christian in the roman
times
i'm not sure i could have withstand
withstood the torture
but these people feel that their faith
is what identifies them it's who they
are and we're talking about 2 000 years
of faith
and of history so what they would say to
me
why do they remain why don't they go to
the to britain why don't they why don't
they convert to islam
because of their love their profound and
deep love of their faith they're linked
to the land and their link to their to
their religion which is of the most
utmost important to their identity
giovanni thank you very much for joining
us on spectator tv
now next how much does the music of the
beatles owe to the beatles and how much
does it owe to the beach boys or for
that matter to bob dylan in a new book
and luke meddings has written about the
relationship between these three groups
of musicians and ian leslie reviews it
for us in this week's magazine he joins
us now
and in this is a bit of a strange idea
isn't it nobody really thinks of the
beatles as being kind of them in any way
kind of dylan epiguns but do you do you
tr how plausible do you think the theory
of symbiosis is between them
i think it's very plausible
and uh
and yeah it's an unusual idea because
we're used to biographies of a certain
artist right a beatles a book about the
beatles book about dylan
and they might include some mentions of
of these other artists but you're kind
of focusing on one and he's he's not
doing that he's saying let's look at all
these three artists and in fact he
includes others as well and let's look
at the whole scene and look at how they
interacted with each other and how they
fed off each other and how they pushed
each other
to create this kind of incredible
moment in the 1960s uh when these kind
of giant leaps were being taken
uh in in popular music so it's an
unusual idea difficult idea to pull off
but i think he does it's a it's a it's a
really really enjoyable book now pretty
much every biography of any musician
will talk about their influences i mean
paul mccartney talks about how he heard
great balls of fire and it
revolutionized how he thought about
music and we see we've seen about elvis
learned from the gospel greats and
created his own sound here but what the
book argues is that there was a kind of
ongoing relationship between these three
that they almost felt in sort of com
competition with each other and if
that's the bit i've got a little bit of
difficulty with that the beach boys
thinking oh the beast the beatles are
catching up with us because you can't
really hear much of response to the
beatles and the beach boys music at
least i can't but perhaps perhaps you
can
i am yeah
because the influence isn't um
always obvious you're right it's it's
and it's not always kind of
literal because and that's kind of
partly just a function of the fact that
these guys are really great
artists in their own right so they're
not just um imitators it's not like the
monkeys you know god bless the monkeys
but the monkeys were setting out to
sound like the beatles and that's what
they did
it works a little bit different when
you're brian wilson and you're kind of
you know something of a genius in your
own right you're taking on board the
influences but you're transforming it as
what at the same time
um it goes through the the prism of your
own kind of artistic worldview so he he
hears uh you know robber soul
and uh by the beatles and he thinks
wow i've really got to up my game and
it's not necessarily that the musical
influence is direct a lot of it's just
the sense of ambition
and and of of innovation and of trying
new things that kind of really pushed
him towards the the pinnacle of pet
sounds and some of the other kind of
great music that they made around that
that time
so and i think meddings is very good at
tracing that that kind of influence it
calls it adaptive influence
i guess you can argue that george martin
showed what musical production was able
to do and at that time it wasn't just
music it was sounds that they were
creating and and then brian wilson was a
great one for creating sounds and then
he had basically these brothers who were
just pretty boys going
but really it was brian wilson who's a
creative genius behind that
um but but
you can see the beach boys music
evolving in production values and the
sounds that they were creating you can't
really see dylan's music evolving in the
same way
yeah he but you know medics is really
good at this because he pointed out a
few things that i hadn't really kind of
thought about
which is
that dylan's move towards a kind of a
poppier and and more electric sound was
partly influenced by the beatles and
he's fantastic he's looking at that
famous point where did you give the
concerts and his fans were walking out
when they heard the
the electric aspect of it coming in
yeah right and even before that you know
songs like love minus zero
he was he was already moving in a kind
of poppier more
you know he started very folky sounding
and he kind of moved towards a poppier
sound and it became more of a band based
sound as well it wasn't just him in his
guitar and that was partly him hearing
the beatles and thinking wow you know
not only are these guys really
successful but what they're doing is
actually quite sophist musically
sophisticated so he was kind of inspired
by as well as impressed by the success
and so he was quietly influenced he was
not the kind of guy to admit it you know
the beatles would own up to their
influences and they would say yeah we
know we love motown we love dylan and
look you know he's influenced us dylan
would never do that you would just see
it in subtle ways creep into his music
but he wouldn't he wouldn't he would
never say you know i i did this because
i heard the beatles and it really turned
me on right and the beatles if you take
back in the ussr for example and that
always struck me as being um well not
just influenced by the beach boys but
almost a pastiche of the beach boys the
beach boys were sing surfing usa the
beatles come back with back in the ussr
the ukraine girls really knocked me out
it seemed to be that sounds like they're
those mocking the beach boys but did
they reach them did the beatles go back
and say to themselves look we think
brian wilson is a creative genius and
we've got to see if we can be inspired
by the leaps he's making
they did they they really rated them i i
agree that back in the u.s as harvard is
close to pasties and you're like are you
just having fun here um
but they there's no question that that
brian wilson in particular i don't think
they actually rated all of the beach
boys you know equally
um but i think they really respect it
mccartney in particular i had a real
real admiration for brian wilson they
became uh pretty friendly and and and
talked a lot about music so yeah that
was a that was a real influence on them
in your review you mentioned there's a
bit where dylan here is the beatles song
tomorrow never knows
and that is just way too psychedelic for
him i mean he's quite dismissive he says
look i get it now the beatles don't want
to be cute anymore is that how we saw it
i mean i just think this moment is
hilarious you know they're in a hotel
because they meet you know this is one
of the interesting things by the way
it's not just them hearing each other's
records they do actually meet in hotel
rooms and clubs in in new york and
london over the years um and the beatles
meet uh one day with with one evening
with with dylan
they play him a new track from from
their forthcoming album revolver is
tomorrow never knows it's this
absolutely what must have been an
absolutely terrifying astonishing
mind-blowing thing to hear nobody had
ever done this kind of psychedelic
one-chord repetitive mantra-like music
before
and he gets to the end of it and instead
of saying wow that's amazing
he just says i get it you guys don't
want to be cute anymore and i just think
it's the most kind of like hilarious put
down
but it also reveals his insecurity you
could i just think i could tell
at the back of his mind he's thinking
wow these guys have taken it to a whole
new level and i'm feeling a little bit
insecure about this so i'm just going to
make a little crack about about being
cute um but then of course he moves on
as well so yeah they're all they're
they're kind of pushing each other
forward even as they're
but they're being they're they're
friends and they're also rivals
um one of the things that i can't work
out is why this process stopped after
all the musical creativity of the 60s
you'd think that there'd be between the
years of like 64 and 67 for example
though it goes on for all of you the
beatles are coming out with inventing
genres pretty much playing music in
every possible way it's imaginable to
compose and play music
and then all of a sudden you get the 70s
coming along where there is nothing
other than a sort of a cabaret band
called abba who seemed to dominate the
decades so what happens to that kind of
competition of musical ideas that seem
to petered out after after these three
i would be a little kinder towards the
70s than you are perhaps but i do think
that was something special
i mean joni mitchell stevie wonder
led zeppelin
um but but i do think there was
something special about that mid 60s
moment
it was a real
uh kind of golden age
and
i don't i i think it didn't last long
because the the principal people
involved with just got exhausted you
know they were working incredibly hard
they were the first pops huge kind of
global pop stars or you know after elvis
um
but they were on a different level from
anyone else and and they were touring
all the time they were recording all the
time and they basically burnt out you
know brian wilson really
went a bit mad and have a nervous
breakdown and had to kind of take time
out dylan had his motorcycle accident
but then it took a long time
you know to rest and recuperate from
that because i think he was basically
burnt out as well
the beatles one of the kind of the
things that struck me actually from
reading the book was wow the beatles
just kept going until they stopped right
but
they just kind of
went off straight through the 60s
without stopping
and then kind of
explode um so one of the things perhaps
we underestimate them is their sheer
persistence
and i think that was slightly
intimidating for for everyone else you
can understand the beatles and the beach
boys you can understand that because
they both really did experiment but if
but where is the influence of dylan
in the beatles where's the influence of
dylan in the beach boys
dylan less on the beach boys i think but
on the beatles
you can hear it in uh john lennon's
increasingly kind of
confessional approach you know so so
lennon in particular was really
taken by dylan and he loved the fact
that dylan would just
speak to you as if he was kind of
bearing his soul about what he was
really feeling and and his emotions and
it was a kind of great emotional
directness to some of these songs which
was very in tune with where lennon
wanted to be anyway but dylan kind of
gave him the confidence
um
uh to be much more kind of forthright in
that department um yeah so so for a
couple of years they're in 65 66
you can hear dylan really kind of
changing the sound of the beatles
perhaps more than any other artist
ian leslie thanks so much for joining us
on spectator tv that's it for this week
you can read interview and all the
articles we've discussed in this week's
issue which is in the shops now or you
can try us for free if you want you can
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash tv offer for our introductory
offer you get a 20 quid amazon voucher
and three months of the magazine thanks
for watching and thanks to our producer
max jeffrey kate andrews will be in the
presenter's chair next week
[Music]
you